From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the summer of 1968, a scientist created a small metal room at the National Institute of Mental Health in Maryland. It was known as Universe 25, and if you got close enough, you could hear its 8 tiny inhabitants, mice. its eight tiny inhabitants. Mice. Tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick,
这里是NPR的《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。1968年夏天，马里兰州美国国家心理健康研究所的一位科学家建造了一个小型金属房间。它被称为“25号宇宙”，如果你凑得够近，就能听到里面8个微小的居民——老鼠。它的八个微小的居民。老鼠。滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，
tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick tick, tick tick, tick, tick, tick, tick, tick tick, tick tick, tick tick, tick, tick tick, tick tick, tick tick, tick, tick tick, tick tick, tick tick tick, tick tick tick, tick tick, tick tick, tick tick tick, tick tick, tick tick tick, tick tick, tick tick tick tick, tick tick, no snow, no wind. All they was to do was eat, play, and reproduce. And reproducing was key because the scientist, John Calhoun, had a question.
滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答，没有风雪，没有狂风。它们唯一要做的就是吃东西、玩耍和繁殖。而繁殖是关键，因为这位名叫约翰·卡尔霍恩的科学家有一个疑问。
What would happen as the population of mice grew larger and the dimensions of the room felt smaller? Would a change in numbers set off a change in behavior. Soon the mice began to have babies. Then those babies grew up and have their own babies, and those babies grow up and have their own babies, and on and on and on. Beluning from dozens of mice to hundreds of mice to thousands of mice all crowded together in a 9-foot-by-9-foot metal room, twitching, scampering, screeching. Soon it didn't feel like a utopia anymore. The details of what happened are disturbing. There were too many young mice and too little space. There were few places to nest and not
随着老鼠种群规模的扩大而房间的尺寸显得越来越小，将会发生什么呢？数量的变化会引发行为的变化吗？很快，老鼠开始生下幼崽。接着这些幼崽长大并有了它们自己的幼崽，而那些幼崽又长大并有了它们自己的幼崽，如此循环往复。老鼠的数量从几十只激增到几百只，再到数千只，它们全部挤在一个9英尺乘9英尺的金属房间里，抽搐着、嬉闹着、尖叫着。很快，这里感觉再也不像乌托邦了。发生的事情的细节令人不安。年轻老鼠太多，而空间太小。筑巢的地方很少，
enough room at the top of the mouse social hierarchy. Eventually a hoard of lower status male mice turned into outcasts, spending all day huddled at the center of the room, vacant and listless. With so many males withdrawn and distracted, nursing females had no one to defend their nests and they became aggressive. Social order broke down. At one point, nearly every mouse in the enclosure had a raw injured tear from being bitten by other mice. After a while, the mice stopped reproducing. Eventually, the entire population was dead. The entire population was dead. John Calhoun watched closely as his rodent heaven became a rodent hell.
在老鼠社会等级的顶端也没有足够的空间。最终，一群地位较低的雄性老鼠变成了流浪者，整天蜷缩在房间中央，眼神空洞、毫无生气。由于如此多的雄性退缩和分心，哺乳期的雌鼠无人协助保卫它们的巢穴，变得具有攻击性。社会秩序崩溃了。有一段时间，围栏里的几乎每只老鼠身上都有被其他老鼠咬伤的红肿伤痕。过了一会儿，老鼠停止了繁殖。最终，整个种群都死了。整个种群都死了。约翰·卡尔霍恩密切注视着他的啮齿动物天堂变成啮齿动物地狱。
And then he reached a controversial conclusion. Universe 25 was a metaphor for us. It was every city, suburb and village projected into the future all around the world. With too many people competing for partners, shelter and social standing, we would eventually destroy ourselves, just like those mice. This week on Hidden Brain, we revisit that dire prediction made half a century ago, and we find a twist in the Doomsday story, far stranger than anything John Calhoun created his mouse utopia, the world has changed dramatically. Many more people live in cities.
随后，他得出了一个充满争议的结论。“25号宇宙”是对我们的一种隐喻。它是对世界各地未来所有城市、郊区和村庄的投射。随着越来越多的人争夺伴侣、住所和社会地位，我们最终将自我毁灭，就像那些老鼠一样。本周的《隐藏大脑》，我们重新审视半个世纪前的那个可怕预言，并在末日故事中发现了一个比约翰·卡尔霍恩创造的老鼠乌托邦更奇怪的转折：世界已经发生了戏剧性的变化。更多的人生活在城市里。
They work at jobs that didn't exist in the 1960s, and their choices about whether to get married and have kids are often very different from those of earlier generations. Jaronnthologist Sarah Harper looks at the connections between these changes and what's happening on a large scale with the planet's population. In her book, how population change will transform our world. She shows how large scale demographic shifts shape intimate aspects of our lives, from the number of children we choose to have, to how we care for aging parents. They also have enormous implications for our economic lives and the well-being of the planet.
他们从事着20世纪60年代并不存在的工作，他们关于是否结婚生子的选择往往与前几代人截然不同。老年学家萨拉·哈珀研究了这些变化与地球人口大规模现状之间的联系。在她的书《人口变化将如何改变我们的世界》中，她展示了大规模的人口结构转变如何塑造我们生活的方方面面，从我们选择生育的孩子数量，到我们如何照顾日渐衰老的父母。它们对我们的经济生活和地球的福祉也具有深远的影响。
Sarah Harper, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. In 1968, Sarah, a Stanford University biologist named Paul Erlich published a book. It was titled The Population Bomb. What was its central message? The central warning of that book was that we were going to have massive out-of-control population growth, so much so that we were going to increase to about 24 billion people on the planet and that that was just going to be totally unsustainable. So I want to play you a little taper by the kinds of fears that books like the Population
萨拉·哈珀，欢迎来到《隐藏大脑》。谢谢你。萨拉，1968年，斯坦福大学的一位生物学家名叫保罗·埃里希，出版了一本书。书名叫《人口炸弹》。它的核心信息是什么？那本书的核心警告是，我们将迎来失控的人口爆炸式增长，增长到地球上大约有240亿人口，而这将是完全不可持续的。所以我想让你听一听《人口炸弹》这类书籍所引发的各种恐惧。我要播放的这段录音来自一部最近的纪录片。听一听。长期以来被预测的人口过剩已经降临到我们头上，并且情况每周都在恶化。在20世纪60年代，一种新型的恐惧开始在美国蔓延。到本世纪末，美国可能会不堪重负。如果我们不通过人道的方式限制我们的人口数量，那么人口数量将通过更多的饥荒、短缺和随之而来的社会冲突来受到限制。
Bombs spurred. This piece of tape I'm going to play you is from a recent documentary. Take a listen. Overpopulation so long predicted as stolen upon us, it's getting worse week by week. In the 1960s, a new kind of fear began to spread across America. The US could be busting out of the seams by day under the century. If we do not by humane means limit our numbers, then numbers are going to be limited by more famines and shortages and consequent social conflicts.
萨拉，我想让你谈谈这个观点，即人们担心人口过剩实际上会摧毁我们，这个观点，萨拉，即人们担心人口过剩实际上会摧毁我们，这种恐惧不仅影响了读书的人，还影响了全世界的政策制定者和规划者，对吧？那是我们真正认为世界人口上限将在本世纪末达到约240亿的时期。如果你还记得的话，欧洲曾出现过一种古老的马尔萨斯观点，那是几百年前出现的，即只要有性行为就会有孩子，而且因为人们渴望性，他们就会一直生孩子。因此，人口将会超出当时世界
I want you to talk about this idea for a moment, Sarah, which is that the fear was that overpopulation could actually destroy us and this idea for a moment, Sarah, which is that the fear was that overpopulation could actually destroy us and this fear influenced not just people reading books, but it influenced policymakers and planners all over the world, right? That was the time when we actually thought that maximum world population was going to hit about 24 billion by the end of this century. If you remember, there was the old Malthusian idea that had occurred in Europe and that had occurred a couple of hundred years earlier, that where you have sex, you have babies and because people wanted sex, they were always going to have babies. And as a consequence, the population was going to outgrow the capacity of the world
已知养活自己的能力。现在，20世纪60年代出现的论点稍微更复杂了一些，但基本上观点是一样的，即我们根本无法养活奶牛，无法养活地球即将迎来的人口数量。因此，人口统计学家有一个术语叫做“替代水平”。这是一种用略显客观的方式来描述一个直观的概念：当一个国家的育龄妇女平均拥有大约两个孩子时。人口保持平稳。如果多于两个，人口就会上升。如果少于两个，人口就会下降。
at known at that time to feed itself. Now, it was a slightly more sophisticated argument that was appearing in the 1960s, but basically the idea was the same that we simply would not be able to feed water cows, the amount of people that the planet was going to expect. So demographers have a term called the replacement level. It's a somewhat clinical way to describe an intuitive concept when women of childbearing age in a country have around two kids on average. The population stays flat. If it's more than two, the population rises. If it's less than two, the population falls.
关于地球上三分之二国家中替代水平，你有一个惊人的统计数据。是什么呢？在人们甚至没有意识到这一点的情况下，我想大约在10到15年前，统计数据开始显现出来，我们实际上在世界上三分之二的国家中，妇女的生育率接近或低于替代水平。这真的很令人惊讶，因为欧洲和北美地区经历了约近200年的时间才完成人口转型，从高生育率过渡到低生育率，
You have an amazing statistic about the replacement level in two thirds of the countries on the planet. What is it? Without us actually realizing this was happening, I would say around about 10 to 15 years ago the statistics began to come through that we were actually in two thirds of the world's countries, women were at near or below replacement. And that was really surprising because it's had taken European and the North American region around about nearly 200 years to go through the demographic transition, to go from high child-bearing to low childbearing,
而在这里，大约短短25年内，我们意识到，特别是亚洲的许多地区、拉丁美洲的许多地区、南欧和东欧，我们看到女性的生育率从相当高的水平下降，在许多情况下甚至降到了两人以下。萨拉所描述的这种转变非常巨大，值得重申。在欧洲和北美的许多地方，妇女逐渐开始少生孩子。这种转变历时两个世纪，但在最近经历这一转型的世界某些地区，同样的转变仅仅用了25年。
and here, suddenly in about 25 years, we realise that, particularly throughout many parts of Asia, many parts of Latin America, Southern and Eastern Europe, we heard women who were coming down from quite large childbearing to many cases under two. The chance that Sarah is describing is dramatic enough that it's worth reiterating. In many parts of Europe and North America, women gradually began having fewer babies. This shift took place over a span of two centuries, but the same shift took only 25 years in parts of the world that went through the transition more recently.
萨拉说，人口统计学家预料到了我们所看到的人口变化，只是没有料到它们的发展速度会如此之快。因为我认为人口统计学家实际上把握了趋势，但他们搞错了速度，我们没有意识到它会发生得如此之快，这真的非常非常重要，因为当我说是我们要达到240亿时，部分原因在于我们生育孩子的速度，以及这种速度会放缓的事实，但它需要这么长时间来放缓，以至于在我们真正开始减少生育之前，人口基数就已经变得极其巨大。而在任何地方出生的每一个女婴
Sarah says that demographers anticipated the population changes we see just not how fast they would unfold. Because I think demographers actually get the trend right but they get the pace wrong and we didn't realize how quickly it was going to happen and that was really really important because when I say we were going to hit 24 billion part of the reason was the pace at which we were having children and the fact that that pace would slow but it was going to take so long to slow that the numbers would be huge before we really started to reduce our child bearing. And every baby girl that's born in any part
世界上，当然，都是潜在的母亲，所以如果你有大量的人口，特别是如果有大量的女孩出生，人口就会非常非常容易地急剧增长。因此，这些人口结构的变化对我们的经济、社会安全网、教育、健康、移民都有着巨大的影响。事实上，很难想象有什么领域不会受到这些变化的触动。我们稍后会讨论这些影响，但我首先想从了解这些变化的本质开始。你看，当国家从高人口增长过渡到平稳的人口时，通常有四个广泛的阶段。
of the world, of course, is a potential mother and so it's very, very easy for populations to just grow dramatically if you have large numbers, particularly of girls being born. So these demographic changes have enormous implications for our economies, for social safety nets, for education, health, for immigration. In fact, it's hard to think of a domain that won't be touched by these changes. And we'll talk about the implications in a moment, but I want to start first by understanding the nature of these changes. You see there are typically four broad stages as countries make the transition from high population growth to flatten population
增长到有时人口在减少。这些阶段是什么，萨拉？所以，我们从非常高的生育率和非常高的死亡率开始。这绝对是200年前欧洲的写照。接下来通常发生的是婴儿死亡率开始下降。由于婴儿死亡率下降，妇女们开始意识到，如果她们生大量的婴儿，她们就会有大量的存活儿童。于是我们进入了第三阶段，生育率下降。最后，我们迎来了低生育率、低死亡率，人们的寿命更长了，我们达到了那个
growth to sometimes a declining population. What are these stages, Sarah? So, we start off with very high levels of childbearing and very high levels of death. That's definitely what Europe was like 200 years ago. Then what typically happens is infant mortality starts to fall. Because infant mortality falls, then women begin to realise that if they have large numbers of babies, they're going to have large numbers of children. So we move into the third stage and childbearing falls. And then eventually we have low childbearing, low death rates, so people are living longer and we reach that
最终阶段，这也是现在大多数高收入国家正在发生的情况，大多数出生的婴儿都有机会过上长寿、健康的生活。因此，在生育率非常高的非洲，我们有大量的儿童。在我们中等收入国家，由于他们减少了孩子数量，因此他们有少量的儿童抚养负担，他们还没有开始老龄化，
final stage, which is what's happening in the majority now of the high income countries, where most babies that are born have the opportunity to live long, healthy lives. So in Africa where we have very high fertility, we have large numbers of children. In our middle income countries, where they've reduced their children, therefore they have a low number of child dependents, they haven't yet started aging,
所以他们的人口红利在于大量的工人，然后我们来到高收入国家，那里生育率低，死亡率低，总的来说我们面临着人口老龄化。在19世纪初，那里的生活并不那么美好。因此，毫无疑问，在英国，我们经历了一个卫生条件非常糟糕的世界。说实话，大多数人吃的是相当糟糕的食物。所以我们必须诚实。我们必须诚实。
so their big boom is in large numbers of workers, and then we come to the high income countries where we have low child bearing, and low death rates, and on the whole we have an aging population. In the early 19th century, life there wasn't so good. So definitely in England we had a world where there was very poor sanitation. Most people are pretty rubbishy food to be perfectly honest. So we had to be honest. We had to be honest.
我们必须诚实。我们必须诚实。我们必须诚实。我们必须诚实。我们必须诚实。所以毫无疑问，在英国，我们经历了一个卫生条件非常糟糕的世界。老实说，大多数人吃的都是相当糟糕的食物。食物分配并不是特别好。因此，疾病很高。人们得了许多感染。他们得的许多感染
We had to be honest. We had to be honest. We had to be honest. We had to be honest. We had to be honest. So definitely in England we had a world where there was very poor sanitation. Most people were pretty rubbishy food to be perfectly honest. Food distribution wasn't particularly good. And as a consequence, disease was high. People got a lot of infections. A lot of the infections they got
仅仅来自于他们生活的环境。农村地区的动物和人类住得非常近。在许多欧洲城镇，我们仍然没有基本的卫生设施。因此，死亡无处不在。但我们在那个世纪所做的事情非常引人注目。我们开始真正改善卫生设施。我们确保有干净的水可用。
was just from the environment that they lived in. Animals and people in rural areas lived very close together. We still didn't have basic sanitation in many European towns. And so death was present everywhere. But what we did across that century was quite remarkable. We started to really improve sanitation. We made sure that clean water was available.
粮食运输系统得到了巨大的增长。突然间，居住在内陆的人们可以吃上鱼了。肉类的供应量增加了。我们甚至有了能够真正妥善保存夏季蔬菜水果的概念。因此，人们变得更健康了，他们能够抵御疾病，并且开始活得更久。
Food transport systems increased tremendously. So suddenly, people who lived in land could be eating fish. the availability of meat. We had even the concept of being able to really properly preserve food from the summer months. And as a consequence, people just became healthier, they could ward off disease, and they began to live longer.
当亚洲和非洲国家开始转型时，疫苗背后的技术以及许多其他公共卫生干预措施已经随时可用。处理废物和输送清洁水的系统已经发明出来。这意味着亚洲和非洲国家在几十年内就能完成欧洲花费了一个多世纪甚至更长时间才完成的事情。由于人口变化的驱动因素在世界不同地区表现不同，萨拉说这导致了各个国家不同人口的膨胀。事实证明，你的国家可能会面临截然不同的挑战和机遇，
By the time Asian and African countries began the transition, the technology behind vaccines and many other public health interventions were readily available. Systems to dispose of waste and to pipe in clean water had been invented. This meant that countries in Asia and Africa could do in decades what had taken Europe a century or more. Because the drivers of demographic change unfolded differently in different parts of the world, Sarah says this has produced bulges in different populations in various countries. It turns out that your country can have very different challenges and opportunities
这取决于有很多年轻人、有很多适龄劳动人口，还是有很多老年人。随着这些国家经历我们所称的人口转型，我们迎来了不同年龄组的人口膨胀，它们确实对社会产生了影响。因此，例如，如果你看看许多仍然位于撒哈拉以南非洲的社会，他们拥有庞大的人口基数。高达40%、45%的人口将是儿童。如果你有一个拥有大量儿童的社会，那么该社会的许多资源，
depending on whether there are a lot of young people, a lot of working-age people, or a lot of old people. As these countries go through what we call the demographic transition, we have these bulges of different age groups and they really have an impact on a society. So, for example, if you look at many of those societies that are still in sub-Saharan Africa, they have huge numbers. Up to 40, 45% of their population will be children. And if you have a society which has large numbers of children, then a lot of those societies resources,
无论是国家资源还是社区、住户和家庭的资源，都集中在抚养这一庞大的儿童人口群体上，即开发他们、教育他们、防止他们死亡、保证他们的安全。这意味着这些社会实际上很难实现跨越，迈向我们所称的人口红利期，也就是我们从幼儿过渡到成年并具备生产能力的时候。
both the national resources and the resources of communities and households and families, is focused on keeping that great big bulge of the population which are children, developing them, educating them, stopping them from dying, keeping them safe. And that means that it's actually quite difficult for those societies, then to make that leap into what we call the demographic dividend, when we move from young children into being adults and able to be productive.
我们可以通过不同的方式进行生产。我们可以在家庭或住户经济中工作。我们可以在正式经济、城市经济或经济体中工作，或者我们可以成为照顾者。但这意味着我们对社会和社区的贡献大于我们从中所取。然后，如果你进入那些正在老龄化的社会，一旦我们拥有的不是那么多的老older成人，而是更虚弱的老年人，也就是那种非常老的人，在许多社会中现在通常是八九十岁的人，他们往往又会消耗社会的资源，而不是必然对社会做出贡献。这就是为什么经济、社区和社会会受到其人口年龄结构膨胀的影响。
And we can be productive in different ways. We can work in the family or household economy. We can work in the formal or the urban or economic economy, or we can be carers. But it means that we are contributing more to our society and our community than we're taking from it. And then if you move into those societies which are aging, once we have not so much older adults but older frailer adults, and that's the sort of very old and typically in many societies now it's people probably in their 80s and 90s, they again tend to draw down on the societies resources rather than necessarily contributing to them. And that's why economies and communities and societies get affected by the bulge in
人口统计学家曾经用金字塔的形象来描述世界上大多数国家的人口面貌。有大量的婴儿和儿童，相当数量的适龄劳动人口，而在金字塔顶端只有极少数的老年人。随着人们寿命的延长，金字塔变成了一座摩天大楼。越来越多的人活到70多岁、80多岁、90多岁。如今，这座摩天大楼越来越多地变成了一个倒金字塔。少量的儿童，不断缩减的适龄劳动人口，以及大量的老年人。当我们回来时，我们将探讨一个许多人寿命超过100岁的世界的挑战与机遇。
the age group of their population. Demographers once used the image of a pyramid to describe what populations look like in most countries of the world. There were lots of babies and kids, a sizable number of working-age people, and a very small number of older people at the top of the pyramid. As people started to live longer lives, the pyramid turned into a skyscraper. More and more people living into their 70s, 80s, 90s. Increasingly today, the skyscraper is turning into an upside down pyramid. A small number of kids, a shrinking working age population, and lots of older people. When we come back, we consider the challenges and opportunities of a world where many people will live past the age of 100.
萨拉·哈珀指出，在许多国家，对人口爆炸的担忧正日益被对人口内爆的担忧所取代。虽然许多贫穷国家的增长仍然迅速，但许多其他国家的增长已经趋于平缓，许多富裕国家则在萎缩。萨拉说，这个故事根源于世界不同地区的妇女能够做出的不同选择。她通过对女性的个案研究来审视这些选择，其中包括她称之为瓦里亚的一位女性。她在一次去新加坡的旅行中遇到了酒店员工瓦里亚。瓦里亚很可爱，我和瓦里亚仍然保持着联系。
Sarah Harper makes the case that concerns over a population explosion have increasingly been replaced in many countries by concerns over a population implosion. While many poor countries are still growing rapidly, many others are flat and lots of rich countries are shrinking. Sarah says this story is rooted in the different choices women are able to make in various parts of the world. She looks at these choices through case studies of women, including a woman she calls Varia. She met Varia, a hotel worker, on a trip to Singapore. Varia is lovely, I'm still in contact with Varia.
所以瓦里亚是一个非常聪明、充满活力、聪明的女性，当我遇到她时，她三十出头，她告诉我她的人生故事，她说当她十几岁的时候，她从马来西亚去了新加坡，并在这些非常大的美国酒店之一找到了一份工作。首先，她是一名基础清洁工，慢慢地她通过自己的努力晋升了，现在她负责客房送餐服务，她对我说，我有一个问题，问题是多年来，我的一位同校男生，住在我的家乡马来西亚，他想娶我，我不想结婚，因为我热爱我在新加坡的生活，
So Varia was a very bright, bouncy, intelligent woman, and when I met her, she was in her early 30s, and she told me her life story, and she said that when she was in her teens, she had travelled from Malaysia to Singapore, and she had got a job in one of these very big American hotels. And first of all, she was the basic cleaner, and slowly she had worked her way up, and now she bought the rum service and she said to me I've got a problem and the problem is that for many years one of the boys that I went to school with who lives in my hometown back in Malaysia he wants to marry me I didn't want to get married because I love my life in Singapore
这家酒店对我真的很好，我在赚钱，我有了生活，我知道如果我结婚了，我将不得不回去和我的家人以及他的家人一起生活，我不想那样。但最终，在几年前，她决定结婚了，她说，现在的问题是，他想要一个孩子。这一次，我将无法在这个时刻对抗家庭。
the hotel is really good to me and I'm earning money I have a life, and I knew that if I got married, I would have to go back and live with my family and with his family, and I didn't want to do that. But eventually, a couple of years previously, she decided to get married, and she said, and now the problem is, he wants to have a baby. And this time, I will not be able to stand out against the family at the moment.
我仍然在酒店工作，但如果我有了孩子，我就必须回到那个社区。但真正有趣的是故事的第二部分，那就是在进行这次对话几年后，我回到了那家酒店，找到了她，我说，你知道，你过得怎么样？你生过孩子吗？她说，是的，我生了，我生了一个小男孩，事实上，酒店对我真的真的很好。他们改变了我的工作时间，但我的儿子由我的婆婆照顾，这太棒了，你知道，事实上我可以兼顾做母亲和在新加坡工作。我说，那另一个孩子呢？她说，绝对不，我只会生一个孩子。而我认为这是一个非常非常戏剧性的故事，它展示了
I'm still working in the hotel, but if I have a child, I will have to be back in that community. But the really interesting thing is the second part of the story, which is that having had this conversation a couple of years later, I went back to that hotel and I tracked her down and I said, you know, how are you? And did you ever have your child? And she said, yes, I did, I had a little boy and in fact the hotel were really, really good to me. And they have changed my hours, but my son is being looked after by my mother-in-law and it's fantastic, you know, in fact I can combine being a mother and working in Singapore. And I said, what about another child? And she said, absolutely not, I will only have one child. And that I think is a really, really dramatic story which shows
这种转变发生得有多快。所以她来自一个非常非常庞大的马来西亚农村家庭，然而她却能够做出只生一个孩子的决定。所以在短短的一代人时间里，你就从六到八个孩子减少到一个，但你可以看到其中的动态，你可以看到为什么会发生这种情况。这个故事揭示了为什么会在短时间内看到生育率发生巨大变化。可以肯定的是，这些变化在世界各地是不均衡的，不仅在国家之间，而且在国家内部也是如此。但是，正如书籍如《人口》或约翰·卡尔霍恩对老鼠的可怕实验中所提出的担忧那样，我们无法养活自己，
about how quickly this transition can occur. So she came from a very, very large rural Malaysian family and yet she had been able to make that decision to have just one child. So in one generation you go from six to eight children down to one, but you can see the dynamics, you can see why that might happen. The story reveals why you see vast changes in fertility rates within a short timeframe. To be sure, these changes are uneven across the planet, not just between countries, but within them. But the concerns raised in books such as the Population, or in John Calhoun's terrifying experiment with mice, that we wouldn't be able to feed ourselves,
饥荒和战争是不可避免的，这种恐怖故事在很大程度上并没有发生。然而，取而代之的是，一个新问题的轮廓正在形成：劳动力不断萎缩的老龄化人口。我们必须理解的是，21世纪是一个真正的人口转型时期，在这个世纪里我们将看到，
that famine and war were inevitable, that horror story has largely not come to pass. In its place, however, the outline of a new problem is taking shape, aging populations with shrinking workforces. What we have to understand is that the 21st century is a real time of demographic transition, that across this century we're going to see,
我们认为，世界上几乎所有的国家，最终都将迎来更少、更老的人口，在这些人口中，我们的寿命更长，生育的子女更少。我想花点时间专门看看美国。它似乎是你所描述的人口趋势中的一个特例。这是一个财富丰厚且人口似乎并未萎缩的国家。所以美国特别有趣。它很富有，经济上仍然充满活力。对于一个发达经济体来说，它的出生率仍然相当高，但它并没有萎缩，因为它仍然拥有相当活跃的净移民政策。如果你比较
we think, nearly all countries in the world, ending up with smaller, older populations where we are living longer and having fewer children. I'd like to spend a few moments looking specifically at the United States. It seems to be something of an outlier in the demographic trends that you're describing. It's a wealthy country that does not seem to be shrinking in population. So the United States is particularly interesting. It is rich, it is economically still vibrant. It still has a reasonably high birth rate for a developed economy, but it's not shrinking because it still has a pretty buoyant in migration policy. If you compare
与两个欧洲国家相比，当我们审视欧洲老龄化国家时，有两个国家不那么老，即英国和法国。这是为什么呢？这是因为我们一直通过向我们的人口中引入熟练和不太熟练的移民来弥补我们的人口老龄化。这提升了我们的生育率，并保持了我们经济的活力。这正是美国一直以来能够做到的事情。我曾经住在芝加哥，我非常喜欢住在芝加哥。
that with two European countries, so when we look at the aging countries in Europe, there are two countries that are less old, the UK and France. Why is that? It's because we've always compensated for our aging by having immigration of both skilled and less skilled peoples into our population. That has boosted our childbearing rate and it's kept our economies buoyant. And that is exactly what the United States has been able to do. I used to live in Chicago and I loved living in Chicago.
我的孩子们去了一所学校，他们过去常叫它彩虹学校，因为那里有来自世界各地的许多不同的人。我认为一个非常重要的教训是，从人口统计学上讲，在世界各地流动实际上是一个非常自然平衡的行为，人们应该欢迎这种机会，既能去到不同的地方，也能接纳来自世界各地的人。它推动了经济，改变了文化，这就是未来。萨拉，在我们为这一集做研究时，我们偶然遇到了另一个萨拉·哈珀，
My children went to a school where they used to call it the Rainbow School because there was so many different people from all over the world. And I think the really important lesson is to say that demographically moving around the world is actually a very natural balancing act, and one should welcome that kind of opportunity both to be able to go out into different places, but also to accept people from across the world. It drives economies and it changes cultures, and it is the future. Sarah, in our research for this episode, we accidentally stumbled on another Sarah Harper,
她也碰巧来自牛津，实际上是牛津村，那是加拿大的一个社区。我想放一段录音给你听。生日快乐，亲爱的萨拉！随着萨拉·哈珀迎来109岁生日，大家齐聚一堂庆祝。她向人群致谢并表达感激。所以萨拉·哈珀在几年前去世了，当时她跨过了110岁的年龄，这使她成为了所谓的超级百岁老人。
who also happens to be from Oxford, well actually Oxford House, and it's a community in Canada. I want to play you some tape. Happy birthday dear Sarah! A celebration, as Sarah Harper turns 109 years old. She thanks the crowd and craze. So Sarah Harper died a couple of years ago, after she crossed the age of 110, which made her what's known as a super centenary.
所以，这个问题是留给你的，萨拉。在未来的几十年里，我们会看到更多像萨拉·哈珀这样的人吗？我认为这太棒了，我也希望如此。是的，目前所有的证据都表明我们的寿命更长了，而且我们最年长的人也活得更久了。所以这一直是一个很大的讨论话题。为什么我们活得更长？我们活得更长是因为在整个生命周期中死亡率开始下降。
So, this question is for you, Sarah. Are we going to see many more Sarah Harper's in the decades to come? I think that's wonderful, and I do hope so. Yes, all the evidence at the moment is that our populations are living longer and our oldest, old, are also living longer. So that was always a big discussion. Why do we live longer? We live longer because death rates start falling across the life course.
而在某一时刻，我们曾认为我们会推迟死亡，你知道的，在150年前的40多岁时平均而言，欧洲一半的人口在40多岁时就去世了。我们曾认为我们会推迟死亡，但实际上一旦我们到了65岁，大多数人还是会在70或80岁时去世。现在我们知道，当我们把死亡进一步推迟时，我们确实开始真正提高了长寿。以至于，例如，最近的一些研究表明，目前在日本出生的婴儿中，有一半人可能会活到107岁。目前在美国出生的婴儿中，有一半人可能会活到104岁左右。哇。所以我觉得这个想法，我的意思是，你知道，我祖母在70多岁时去世了，
And at one point, what we thought was that we would push back death, which was, you know, on average in the 40s, one, you know, half the population of Europe was dead by their mid 40s, 150 years ago. We thought we would push death back, but actually once we got to 65, most people would be dead by 70 or 80. Now we know that as we push death back further and further, so we're really beginning to increase longevity. So much so that, for example, some recent research suggested that half the babies that are currently born in Japan, are likely to make it to 107. Half the babies currently born in the US will make it to about 104. Wow. So I think this idea, I mean, you know, my grandmother died in her early 70s,
每个人都说，哦，太棒了，我祖母在70多岁时去世了，每个人都说，我们过得很棒，她在70多岁时去世了。如今，如果人们在70多岁时去世，你会说，天哪，他们还很年轻，因为在我们的高收入国家中，我们已经将死亡推后了，以至于我们期望大多数人能活到80多岁，而且我们知道，有很多很多的人能活到80多岁甚至90多岁。百岁老人的数量正在急剧增加。我的意思是，我们在美国对百岁老人进行了一些建模。到本世纪末，美国将有超过600万的百岁老人同时生活。所以有些人
and everyone went, well, great life my grandmother died in her early 70s and everyone went, we have a great life, she died in her early 70s. Nowadays, if people die in their early 70s, you go, gosh, they're young because we have pushed back in our high income countries so that we expect most people to make it into their 80s and we know that, you know, many, many people make it into their late 80s or even 90s. And the number of centenarians is increasing dramatically. I mean, we did some modeling of centenarians in the States. And by the end of the century, you will have well over 6 million centenarians living at the same time in the US. So some people
将21世纪称为百岁老人的世纪。你所描述的人口变化的主要影响之一与所谓的抚养比有关。这个数字是什么，萨拉？所以抚养比通常是指处于工作年龄、因此可以说具有生产力并进行生产的人数，与那些超过这个年龄的人数之比。人们对此感到非常担忧，因为他们说，看，历史上我们是一个老年人对应五个工人，而现在我们每个老年人只有两个工人了。
call the 21st century the century the centenarian. One of the major implications around the demographic changes you describe has to do with something called the support ratio. What is this number, sir? So the support ratio is typically the number of people who are of working age and therefore if you like producing and being productive to those people who are over that age. And people get very worried about that because they say, look, historically we had five workers to one older person and now we're only going to have two workers to every one older person.
萨拉强调，抚养比缩小的影响并非遥远的未来。我认为我们必须理解的一点是，这并不是将要发生，而是正在发生。因此我想说，在大多数高收入国家，大多数50多岁甚至60多岁的男女——不是千禧一代，而是50多岁甚至60多岁的男女——实际上已经感受到了人口老龄化的影响。如果你回看20、30年前，我们并没有大量80多岁和90多岁的人。现在有了。大多数50多岁和60多岁的人要么在照顾、协助支持老年人，要么已经照顾过老年人。这正在发生。我的意思是，特别是
Sarah emphasizes that the effect of a shrinking support ratio are not in the distant future. I think one of the things we have to understand is that it isn't going to happen, it's happening now. So I would say that in most high-income countries, most men and women, not millennials, but most men and women in their 50s and even 60s, are actually already feeling the impact of the aging population. So if you go back and you look 20, 30 years ago, we didn't have huge numbers of people in their 80s and 90s. Now we do. And most people in their 50s and 60s are either caring for, helping to support or who have cared for older adults. It's happening now. I mean, the strain on particularly
40多岁后期和50多岁的女性，我认为压力是非同寻常的。因此，女性被要求进入劳动力市场。其中一些人正在成为杰出的祖母，并被要求照顾孙辈，以便他们的孩子能够进入劳动力市场。但她们还要照顾70多岁和80多岁的年迈父母。在某些情况下，她们还要照顾祖父母。我想谈谈正在发生的变化可能会如何影响社会保障网。谈谈正在发生的变化可能会如何影响社会保障网。
women in their late 40s and 50s, I think is extraordinary. So women are asked to be in the labour market. Some of them are becoming grand extraordinary. So women are asked to be in the labour market. Some of them are becoming grandmothers and are being asked to look after the grandchildren and say that their children can go into the labour market. But they're also caring for their older parents who are in their 70s and 80s. And in some cases, they're caring for their grandparents. I want to talk a little bit about how the changes that are underway might affect social security nets. to talk a little bit about how the changes that are underway might affect social security
当我们最初设立养老金时，在它们将支持人们多长时间方面，我们心里是怎么想的？正在进行的人口变化又如何改变或复杂化了这一图景？关于养老金的事情是，我们最初究竟为什么要建立养老金制度。当养老金被引入时，它们并不是为了让人们在工作生涯结束后能够享受长期的闲适。这并不是说这不是一件实际上非常受益的事情，但这并不是它的全部意义所在。
nets. When we first created pensions, what did we have in mind in terms of how long they would support people and how have the demographic changes underway changed or complicated that picture? The thing about pensions is exactly why did we have a pension system to start with. And when pensions were introduced, they weren't to enable to people to have long periods of leisure after a working career. That's not to say that isn't something that actually is quite beneficial, but that's not what it was all about.
它只是为了在人们死前的最后几个月，有时是几个月，或者仅仅是一两年内支持他们，因为他们不再能够工作了。为了将这一点放在一个视角来看，当俾斯麦将老年养老金的概念引入欧洲时，一半的欧洲人口在45岁时就已经去世了，然而他却将65岁定为养老金开始发放的年龄。如果你想现在以此进行外推，实际上高收入国家的国家养老金领取年龄应该是103岁。
It was just to support people in the last few, sometimes months, or just one or two years before they died, because they were no longer able to work. And to put it into perspective, when Bismarck introduced the concept of the old age pension into Europe, half of the European population was dead by 45 and yet he took 65 at the age at which the pension should start. So if you want to extrapolate that now, actually state pension ages in high income countries should be 103.
其他报告表明，俾斯麦将退休年龄设定为70岁。无论确切数字是多少，这都表明现代的可比退休年龄将明显高于今天。因为我们有一半的人口现在能活到80岁。所以你可以看到，一个曾经是安全网的系统在20世纪是如何演变成这样一个概念的：人们觉得他们有权在他们生命的晚期享受这段有资金支持的闲适生活，
Other reports suggest that Bismarck set the retirement age at 70. Whatever the exact number, it suggests that a comparable retirement age in modern times would be significantly higher than it is today. Because half our population makes it now to 80. So you can see how a system that was a safety net became in the 20th century, if you like a concept where people felt that they had a right to this period of funded leisure at the under their lives,
而且我认为没有人会对此进行反推。只是它不再是5年或10年，而是在某些情况下，是我们生命晚期20年或30年有资金支持的闲适生活。我认为人们开始说，当我们不仅有寿命更长的人，而且此刻，庞大的婴儿潮出生组，
and I think nobody will push back against that. It's just that instead of it being five or 10 years, it's actually in some cases 20 or 30 years of funded leisure at the end of our lives. And I think people are beginning to say that that is just unsustainable when we are going to have, remember, not only people living longer, but at the moment, the large baby boom cohorts,
所有人同时进入老年时，这是根本不可持续的。所以我真正听到你所说的是，人口变化确实引发了严肃的道德问题，因为政府需要决定将资源分配给谁。你显然可以同时投资于年轻人和老年人，但在某个时刻会存在权衡，政策制定者将不得不直面这些问题。我认为非常有趣的事情之一，我在书中也说过，在一个
all coming up into old age at the same time. So what I'm really hearing you say is that population changes really raise serious moral questions because governments need to decide who to distribute resources to. You can obviously invest in both the young and the old, but at some point there are trade offs and policymakers are going to have to confront them. I think one of the really interesting things, which I say in the book, is to grow old in
自身正在老龄化的社会中变老，与在一个年轻的社会中变老截然不同。如果你看看例如非洲的情况，那里有许多老年人，但由于有大量的年轻人，他们在人口中所占的比例非常小。因此，大部分资源都投资在了年轻人身上。如果你看看美国，特别是许多欧洲国家，以及我们的一些远东国家，如韩国和日本，那里有非常非常少的年轻人以及大量且占比很高的老年人，资源不可避免地会转移给老年人。我认为我们现在正在谈论的事情之一就是我们所称的“代际契约”。代际契约无处不在。
a society that is self-aging is very different from growing old in a young society. If you look at the case, for example, in Africa, where there are so many older adults, but there are very small percentage of the population, because there are so many young people. And therefore, most of the resources are invested in young people. If you look at the states, and in particular, many European countries, and some of our far eastern countries, like Korea and Japan, where they have very, very few young people and a large number and a large percentage of older adults, inevitably resources are going to be shifted to the older adults. And I think one of the things that we now are talking about is what we call the generational contract. And the generational contract exists everywhere.
它的理念是，当你成为成年人时，你抚养一个孩子，然后这个孩子长大了，你变老了，孩子照顾你。在传统社会中，这会在住户或家庭内部完成，你实际上是在身体上照顾年迈的父母和祖父母；而在现代社会中，我们通过医疗保健、长期护理、养老金来做到这一点，年轻人纳税，这资助了整个老年人支持系统。我认为目前确实存在一种强烈的反弹，同样是因为这一代极其庞大的婴儿潮一代极大地扭曲了人口结构，以至于一些年轻
And it's the idea that when you are an adult, you have a child you look after that child and then that child grows up you become elderly and the child looks after you and in a traditional society that will be done within the household or the family you actually physically care for your older parents and grandparents and in a modern society we do it through healthcare, long-term care pensions, and young people pay taxes, and that funds a whole system of support for older people. And I think there's a real pushback at the moment, again, because of this very, very large generation of baby boomers who are really distorting the population that some young
人在说，实际上，我们应该重新思考这一点吗？一些老年人在说，也许我们需要工作更长时间，我们需要能够储蓄更多，我们需要真正审视养老金运作的整个方式，以便在我们经历这个世纪正在发生的老年人口膨胀时，我们能够更多地在晚年照顾好自己。因此，一些富裕国家正试图扭曲人口下降的趋势，部分是出于对这些趋势的考虑。你提到了罗马尼亚和法国这两个试图提高出生率的国家作为例子，但它们采取的方式截然不同。它们学到了什么，我们又能从它们那里学到什么？
people are saying, actually, should we rethink this? And some older people are saying, maybe we need to work longer, we need to be able to save more, we need to really look at the whole way that pensions work, so that we can look after ourselves in our old age much more as we go through this sort of bulge of older adults, which is occurring across this century. So some rich countries are trying to reverse declines in population, partly keeping these trends in mind. You mentioned the examples of Romania and France as two countries that have tried to increase their birth rates, but they went about it in very different ways. What did they learn and what can we learn from them?
我认为来自那些试图提高生育率的国家的教训是。当然，在罗马尼亚，这是非常严厉的。他们绝对禁止了基本上是避孕和堕胎，并强迫女性生孩子。而一旦那个特定的政权倒台，他们的出生率就直线下降。罗马尼亚现在是欧洲生育率最低的国家之一。
I think the message from those countries that have tried to boost fertility. And of course, in Romania, it was very draconian. They absolutely banned, basically contraception and abortions, and they forced women to have children. And as soon as that particular regime fell, then their birth rate just plummeted. In Romania now has one of the lowest birth rate in Europe.
法国采取了非常不同的做法。法国试图提供经济激励。但我认为我们必须退一步来看。我们知道我们的环境面临着巨大的压力，高收入因此，我认为我们真的必须问问自己，高收入国家试图增加其生育的儿童数量并因此增加对我们地球的消耗，这样做真的对吗？第二件事是
France has done it very differently. France has tried to give financial incentives. But I think we have to step back. We know that there is huge pressure on our environment, and high-income countries consume far more than any other people on this planet. And therefore, I think we really have to ask ourselves, is it right for high-income countries to try and boost the number of children they have, and therefore increase the consumption that they have on our planet? And the second thing
法国采取了截然不同的做法。法国试图提供财政激励。但我认为我们必须退一步来看。我们知道我们的环境面临着巨大的压力，高收入国家的人均消费量远超地球上任何其他人。因此，我认为我们确实必须反问自己，高收入国家试图增加生育率，从而加剧对地球资源的消耗，这样做究竟对吗？其次
is, demographically, it simply doesn't work. So, hungry at the moment, for example, is a country which is trying to encourage women to have more children, because they're worried about their declining population and the falling number of workers in their population. They don't want to use immigration, which is the natural way to support an aging population. If they're successful, all they're going to do is they're going to have 20 years of lots and lots of children because it takes 20 years before you have basically a baby able to go into the labour market. So they're going to have lots of older dependents, lots of younger dependents, they're actually going to make, if you like, the support ratio or the dependency ratio that is workers to dependents worse, and all they're doing is just delaying the aging of their
从人口统计学的角度来看，这根本行不通。因此，比如匈牙利现在正试图鼓励女性生育更多孩子，因为他们担心人口不断下降以及人口中劳动人口数量减少。他们不想使用移民，而移民本来是支持老龄化人口的自然方法。如果他们成功了，他们所做的一切也只是迎来长达20年的大量儿童生育期，因为基本上需要20年时间，婴儿才能进入劳动力市场。所以他们会有很多老年抚养人口、很多年轻抚养人口，如果你愿意的话，这实际上会让劳动人口与被抚养人口的支持比例或抚养比例变得更糟，他们所做的只是推迟了人口的老龄化。
population. So it's better that we should understand that you don't need large numbers of people in the 21st century to drive an economy. There's a world where the shrinking population is that a good thing when it comes to climate change. I want to talk about a couple of the potentially positive implications of the changes we're seeing. And it seems to me from what you just said that a smaller world is potentially a world that has less impact on the environment. Absolutely. I mean, nowadays we don't talk so much about population size as population consumption or carbon footprint. And I have to say one of the worst countries, I'm really sorry about this, is the US. You consume per person four or five times
因此，我们最好明白，在21世纪，你并不需要大量的人口来驱动经济。在人口萎缩的世界里，这对于气候变化来说是一件好事吗？我想谈谈我们所见证的变化的一些潜在积极影响。在我看来，根据你刚才所说，一个更小的世界可能是一个对环境影响更小的世界。绝对是这样。我的意思是，现在我们不再过多谈论人口规模，而是谈论人口消费或碳足迹。我不得不说，其中一个最糟糕的国家，对此我真的很抱歉，那就是美国。人均消费量是大多数非洲人的四到五倍
the earth resources as most Africans do. Europeans wear two to three times more. We all have a responsibility to say, look, it's unthinkable that people in the southern hemisphere are going to live in the kind of poverty that they're living across the coming decades. We've got to allow them and support them to increase their consumption of food and water and goods and raise their standard of living. And the only way we can do that is by reducing the consumption in the north. And one way we can do that is by not having large numbers of children that are going to contribute to our overall consumption. So I think a declining population a'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
欧洲人多两到三倍。我们所有人都有责任去表明，看吧，南半球的人们在未来几十年里继续生活在他们目前那种贫困中是不可想象的。我们必须允许并支持他们增加对食品、水和商品的消费，提高他们的生活水平。我们能做到这一点的唯一方法就是减少北方的消费。我们可以做到这一点的方法之一，就是不生育大量会增加我们整体消费的孩子。因此，我认为人口下降……
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r then died at a very old age. Well, that's what we should be aiming for, so that we have long lived people who are contributing across their lives, their healthy and fit, and we really sort of squash
然后在高龄时去世。嗯，这正是我们应该追求的目标，这样我们就能拥有长寿的人，他们在整个生命周期中都在做贡献，他们健康且充满活力，而我们确实把虚弱期压缩到了生命最后的阶段，这样我们就不必担心人口老龄化了。……萨拉说，她在世界各地看到的许多人口变化也出现在她自己的生活中。
frailt independence, just into the end of our lives, and then we don't have to be worried about an aging population. ... Sarah says many of the demographic changes she sees around the world have also shown up in her own life. So 15 years ago my parents moved to my village and they were fantastic active grandparents
所以在15年前，我的父母搬到了我的村子，他们对我的家庭来说是极好的、充满活力的祖父母，我有三个孩子，真的非常棒。然后在大约六七年前，他们变得有点虚弱了，接着在四年前，我父亲非常非常突然地去世了，留下了90岁出头的母亲。她搬来和我们一起住，我们照顾了她两年，然后她去世了。
for my family, I've got three children, absolutely wonderful. And then about six or seven years ago, they became a little bit frailer and then four years ago, my father very, very suddenly died and left my mother who was in her early nineties. And she moved in with us and we cared for her for two years and then she died. And so I would say that I, like nearly everyone I know, had this period of four or five years where I was completely focused on the well-being of my parents. And as I say, So I would say that nearly everyone I know had this period of four or five years where I was completely focused on the well-being of my parents. And as I say, just everyone I know of my age is in that situation.
所以我想说，就像我认识的几乎所有人一样，我也有过四五年的时间，完全专注于父母的福祉。正如我所说，所以我想说，我认识的几乎所有人都有过四五年的时间，完全专注于父母的福祉。正如我所说，我认识的同龄人无一例外都处在这种情况下。
But I have to say it was also fantastic for my children. So my children were in their late teens just tipping into their 20s. They were at university, but they were coming home a lot. And I think being with my parents, their grandparents, at that stage of their lives, was an incredibly rewarding thing. I mean, they were all with my mother who died at home. And I think they learnt so much about the value of life.
但我必须说，这对我的孩子们来说也棒极了。当时我的孩子们正处于十几岁的末期，即将迈入20岁。他们在上大学，但经常回家。我认为在他们生命中的那个阶段，和我的父母、他们的祖父母在一起，是一件极其有意义的事情。我的意思是，他们都陪着在家去世的母亲。而且我认为他们从中学到了很多关于生命价值的东西。
And in particular, you could say that my mother, when she was in her 90s, you could say she wasn't contributory, but she was incredibly contributory. She really contributed to our family by being an older person, living with us, Mae'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi'n gweithio'r ymwch chi' valued my mother's experiences. And so yes, it has been a very personal journey over the last few years. Sarah Harper is a professor of gerontology at the University of Oxford. She is the author of how population change
特别地，你可以说我的母亲在她90多岁时，你可能会说她没有贡献，但她实际上做出了惊人的贡献。她作为一个老人和我们住在一起，真正对我们的家庭做出了贡献……珍视我母亲的经历。所以是的，这是过去几年里非常个人的一段旅程。萨拉·哈珀是牛津大学的老龄学教授。她是《人口变化将如何改变我们的世界》一书的作者。
will transform our world. Sarah, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. This week's show was produced by Lushik Waba and Laura Quarell. It was edited by Reina Cohen and Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Path Shah, Thomas Liu and Kat Schucknick. Our unsung hero this week is Alison Hoffer. She's a support engineer with NPR's Digital Media team. That means she's one of the
萨拉，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你。本周的节目由露希克·瓦巴和劳拉·夸雷尔制作。雷娜·科恩和塔拉·博伊尔进行了剪辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、帕斯·沙、托马斯·刘和卡特·舒克尼克。我们本周的无名英雄是艾莉森·霍夫尔。她是美国国家公共电台数字媒体团队的支持工程师。这意味着她是当我们的播客发布出现问题时
people who respond to our pleas for help when something goes wrong in publishing our podcast. Thank you, Alison, for working so hard to troubleshoot technical snafu's and for doing so with calmness and collegiality. For more Hidden Brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like today's show, please remember to share it with one friend. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
响应我们求助的人之一。谢谢艾莉森，感谢你如此努力地解决技术故障，并始终保持冷静和合作精神。想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在脸书和推特上找到我们。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请记得分享给一位朋友。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是美国国家公共电台。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。